sur le tarmac ce matin point météo et
dernières consignes à quelques minutes
du départ la pression monte pour romane
la locale de l'étape c'est l'excitation
et la concentration
la rigueur c'est un tour de france
aérien réservé aux jeunes de 18 à 24 ans
45 pilotes sélectionnés sur une centaine
de candidats tous amateurs et pour
coacher cette nouvelle génération des
hommes en jaune comme kevin il souffle
les ultimes conseils
c'est très bonne expérience pour elle
d'avoir le 2e tour qui part dc de
chartres donc elle et elle est très très
motivés ça se sent et puis elle est
vraiment dynamique fait un bon score je
pense sur le tour concentration maximale
avec soixante dix huit heures de vol au
compteur romane espère prendre de
l'expérience
ma passion pour l'aviation alors c'était
d'abord le ciel je voulais monter dans
le ciel très près aux parce que je
trouve ça fascinant est magnifique et
puis je me suis rendu compte qu'à strotz
était peut-être un peu compliqué comme
première étape donc je me suis je vais
descendre d'un étage et je restais sur
l'idée que vous l'êtes
il s'élance un an pour rallier chartres
à la pointe bretonne trois heures de
navigation à bord de mode actif d'aero
club des roumains
la peep heures pour voir passer le
peloton il va falloir lever les yeux au
ciel pas de maillot jaune ici les
épreuves sont basés sur la technicité
pour eux c'est un aboutissement d'un
rêve et ils vont vivre une expérience
fantastique pendant quinze jours
d'abord en terme d'heures de vol en
termes de pilotage mais ont surtout se
poser sur des endroits où habituellement
ils peuvent pas se poser comme là où
nous allons aujourd'hui à landivisiau
sur la base de l'aéronavale qui est le
nid des rafale de la marine
de quoi en jeter plein la vue lors des
sept étapes du tour parmi le nuage
d'aéronefs brauman rêve d'une carrière
de pilote et espère laisser son
empreinte dans les airs celle d'une
ambassadrice du ciel